hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the moral machine now
what is the moral machine well it's in
reference to autonomous driving and the
moral ambiguity of what the AI should do
while it's in charge of your car and you
may be thinking that autonomous driving
is something down the road and in the
future but in reality it's already here
Tesla just released a video showing
their car fully driving from point A to
point B through crowded streets
real-life scenarios in broad daylight
without any interaction from the person
in the car and you may be thinking oh
that's just a tech demo but even today
there's more and more cars with
autopilot features that take them down
the highway all by themselves so there
is a dilemma in this autonomous driving
if you're driving down the road you have
a choice
if someone leaps out in front of your
car and you are going to hit them and
definitely kill them you have a choice
to swerve out of the way or continue
forward now this seems like a no-brainer
to me at least because my car is built
to save my life the human body in front
of me is built to not withstand a car so
for me it's an obvious choice I would
swerve but what would the car do and
that's the question that we have to ask
here
what should the car do should the car
protect its occupant its owner above all
else or should it do calculations to
determine who should die
now in another scenario imagine that
you're driving down the highway and
there is a group of children in front of
you and you are guaranteed to kill every
single one of them if you keep driving
down the road but you're on a bridge and
if you drive off the road you will fall
to your death
choice becomes harder now what would the
computer do would it calculate that five
is more than one and kill you in my mind
that's it's still an easy choice I would
rather die than five children but it's
not up to me if there's complete
autonomous driving
how do lawmakers make that decision what
if there's someone in front of you
you're not on a bridge but swerving
means that you go into oncoming traffic
in that case you might have to actually
keep going forward even further how many
people in front of you would you have to
kill to be more than the people that you
would kill by swerving in front of
traffic these are the choices that an
autonomous car would have to do and
these are the choices that we as drivers
have to face so let's decide so this
one's simple
what should the self-driving car do
should it kill three occupants an entire
family or these two people here
what would the car decide there's no
punishment for being one or the other so
this is these are the scenarios I just
presented to you but now I actually have
to make a choice for this and this is
guaranteed death guaranteed death this
isn't like oh the car might actually
airbags might deploy it might be okay no
this is guaranteed death you're
careening down the road at a hundred
miles an hour there's no way you're
gonna survive that obstacle see in my
mind in my mind in this scenario it
doesn't matter that it's one elderly
woman one criminal and one boy three
people versus two people and it even
tries to paint the other people as
superior people one male athlete one
female executive in the introduction of
autonomous driving does it come down to
a number scenario I can't stay here
forever
have to make a choice and I have to go
with 3 is greater than 2 and that's it
that's it there's no punishment for it
now here's another scenario what should
the car do should it swerve to avoid the
two people in front of it and also kill
everyone else who is obeying the law
signal here they're obeying the walk
signal or should it continue on and kill
these two people in my mind is a little
easier than the other one five is
greater than two and they're not looking
at the walk signal I mean seems obvious
to me Oh
Bodo should it kill five people or five
in moles three cats and two dogs oh I
hate to say it but I think it should
kill with dogs and cats and that's
horrible to say out loud but these are
the choices oh now it's perfectly even
what should a self-driving car do should
it try to save its occupants or should
it kill the people walking the strange
thing is that if I was in that car if
I'm gonna put in literal scenario it's
me and Tyler in that car we're driving
down the road not doing a thing the car
is taking us where we want to go I feel
like if it was two versus two if I was
in that car I would rather it kill us
than two other people and that's a big
thing for me to say to Tyler you know
about Tyler Lee hey sorry buddy looks
like we're gonna die oh well nice
knowing ya like it's that that's a
that's not an easy thing for me to say
but if I'm in that car I'm okay with
assuming the risk that I might die in
this autonomous driving car I think it
should kill TIA
here's another one like visit this is it
the same scenario but the but the thing
is that lady is not obeying the traffic
signal should it swerve out of the way
and kill its occupant definitely do that
in this scenario in this Center in this
specific scenario how would the car know
that it's that the person is crossing
the street not at the right time in all
honesty the lady is not crossing at the
right time she is literally crossing
when she's not supposed to do that car
should continue oh this is this is the
same scenario but just two men versus
two women it's the same choice this is
this is another scenario we've got a man
a homeless person a criminal and a woman
two female doctors a man and a woman but
they're crossing at the wrong time the
signal is red they are not supposed to
cross if they're not supposed to cross
they're not supposed to be there but
does that deserve death does that
deserve death I don't know in this
scenario I have to go with what I said
before like if people are paying
attention and should follow the
instructions but does should that cost
them their life I think so in the case
where the only determining factor is if
is is someone obeying the traffic signal
or not hey hey it's not good it's not
good no god oh no oh no they're both
doing fine should it kill an old lady
and a guy or a woman and a boy in my
mind and this is me being logical about
it the old lady is an old lady and the
kid
as a kid I'd save the kid this is four
versus five this is a number
determination you got to kill the lesser
amount there's kids in both scenarios
got to kill the lesser amount all right
now here here here here is like a
perfectly a perfectly symmetrical
equation there's a female doctor and a
girl and a male doctor and a boy doesn't
matter the gender it's a man it's a it's
an adult in a kid adult in the kid in
both scenarios should the car continue
its path or swerve to avoid this one is
probably the toughest decision in this
scenario and I say that knowing there's
10 of 13 left so honestly who knows what
questions they have lying ahead but what
I see here is it breaks down to this the
autonomous car can scan the road ahead
better than we ever could my dad when he
was teaching me to drive he taught me to
always look ahead down the road see
routes of escape see what would happen
if there was an accident and know where
you're going to go but an autonomous car
can do that with greater attention span
than I ever could so it would know that
there's four people on the road it would
know there's two people in those
scenarios but what I see here
fundamentally is the car on the Left
taking an action to try to avoid an
accident even if it results in the same
loss of life it's taking an action in
the first in the second scenario in this
scenario here it's continuing on without
taking an action and preventing a
possibility scenario if it does
something if it does something scenarios
change and who knows what could happen
if it swerves out of the way but if it
continues on the path it's guaranteed in
this scenario
guaranteed death yes I understand that
it's guaranteed death in both scenarios
but what I see fundamentally is the car
taking action
on the Left versus the car continuing on
the path I would rather it take an
action than not because when you deviate
you change possibility that's the only
thing that I could say out of this I
don't think either is a right choice
here because if it's determining just on
loss of life alone there is no way to
determine which one's better so I'm
going to fundamentally define it by
action versus inaction and this is this
is a similar scenario this is just four
people versus four people it just so
happens that some are athletic and some
are not maybe they could run away faster
I have no idea but I have to determine
the same outcome that I used in the last
one its action versus inaction and maybe
they're stirred here is not good oh boy
five people versus five animals and
again in this scenario and the big the
animals and it's going in coinciding
with the action in action thing that I
was talking about oh now it's completely
equivalent oh no it's not they're not
obeying the traffic laws hahahaha
they're they're they're flouting the law
by crossing on a rag doll so in this
scenario it's hard to say it's hard to
say it really really really hard to say
but they are judging by my previous
logic they are not crossing at the right
time there is a definitive obstacle on
the other side that results in
guaranteed death
gotta go is this one oh geez we'll see
most saved character this dude most cool
oh oh no oh no oh no so this is my
breakdown saving more lives matters
protecting passengers matters a little
more upholding upholding the law there's
a lot to me avoiding intervention now
they're saying that avoiding
intervention matters a lot to me but I
don't think that's entirely true I was
doing it judged based on what the laws
was saying in terms of going forward and
going back protecting passengers I seem
to have a bit of a bias for but I
totally understand that the overall feel
is that it should protect you know
everybody in my mind in my mind in
real-world application in reality here I
fully believe that the car should take
action to protect the people in front of
it because the car is built with airbags
and humans are not in reality I believe
that but in this specific scenario where
death death is guaranteed you have to do
different outcomes but in reality in
reality I feel like it should be biased
to take action more than it should take
inaction so it's a little not accurate
to my interpretation of what it is
because I fully believe that in real
world scenarios it should definitely
take action and hit something else to
protect its passengers but I definitely
believe that abiding the law and
following the signals and if people pay
attention then things should run
smoothly but I know in reality people
don't do that also apparently I have a I
have an extreme gender preference I'm
pretty sure I killed some dudes I'm
pretty sure I killed a lot of dudes
species preference humans versus pets
age preference young versus old Fitness
preference large people versus fit
people I don't think that's true at all
either now this is this is a really
weird split for me because I am
completely on one side or another
according to this like this quiz I am
completely about saving more lives
I'm completely about upholding the law I
apparently have a complete preference
for females which I'm again I'm pretty
sure I killed a lot of guys there I'm
completely preferable to hoomans I'm
completely preferable to the younger and
I'm completely preferable to large
people which again really sure I know
fit people but and then in social value
it does not matter I might actually be a
robot myself so anyway that is the moral
machine now what would you guys think in
these scenarios what would you have the
car do you can decide for yourself
through the link in the description
below and I actually want to hear your
results so let me know what you think
let me know what you got let me know if
it deviated from this scenario here the
results may surprise you
so anyway thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye
[Music]